xavier moreau directeur de strates paul
centre d'analysé politico-stratégique
bonjour xavier moreau merci d'être en
direct avec nous depuis moscou alors
rien ne vaut un vrai bon face à face un
pour s'expliquer c'est en tout cas ce
que souhaitait joe biden en lançant
cette invitation à vladimir poutine
on y est à genève quel regard porte
justement les russes sur cet entretien
qui va avoir lieu dans quelques minutes
allez les russes en fait en dix ans les
élites russes allaient les commentateurs
n'attendent pas grand-chose de cette de
cette de cette rencontre
enfin cela dit c'est ce qu'ils disent
mais en fait ce que tout le monde le
comprend bien c'est que c'est déjà une
victoire pour vladimir poutine puisque
joe biden qui était le vice-président de
barack obama à l'époque où justement
barack obama disait que la russie
n'était qu'une puissance régionale
or aujourd'hui la rencontre poutine
baril donnent ce sera sera le pour
l'instant le grand moment de politique
étrangère de 2021 alors à moins qu'on
ait une rencontre by downloading ping ce
qui n'est pas exclu
c'est un fait donc en fait les états
unis ont été obligés de reconnaître que
la russie n'est pas cette puissance
négligeable qu'elle était devenue dans
les années 90 et même jusqu'au début des
années 2000 donc en ce sens cela déjà
pour les russes cette perception est
clair c'est que la russie est au coeur
du jeu du grand jeu international la
russie dans le viseur des des états unis
on sait qu'on n'aura pas les mêmes
images
que ce que l'on avait pu voir lors du
sommet d'helsinki à l'époque c'était
donald trump qui a rencontré donc
vladimir poutine pas de conférence de
presse commune aujourd'hui est ce que la
question une des questions les plus
sensibles au coeur de la rencontre
aujourd'hui sera également là des
informations en ligne d attaque
informatique on sait que washington
accuse sans preuve
moscou d'être derrière des super
attaques
la russie a déjà pour leur proposer
depuis longtemps de coopérer sur la
lutte contre les cyber attaques mais je
pense que ce ne sera pas un sujet qui
sera particulièrement abordés par ce que
joe biden sait pertinemment que de la
même manière que les ingérences russe
supposée dans les élections américaines
sont sains sont une fac news pour faire
un anglicisme
et bien tout c'est toutes ces histoires
de cyberattaques sont ne servent qu'à
maintenir une année de tensions entre
washington et moscou donc je pense qu'on
dira sur des sujets plus concret
d'ailleurs il suffit de voir la
délégation qui entoure la dîmière
poutine vous avez lavrentiev qui est le
spécialiste de la syrie
donc pour les russes vous avez cosaques
et le spécialiste de l'ukraine pour les
russes vous avez guerre asimov qui est
chef d'état major de l'armée russe c'est
à dire qu'on va parler des traités de
contrôler les armements on va parler des
armes l'hypersonique donc on va aller
sur des questions mon avis très concrète
et je pense aussi que vous avez la
présence des deux ambassadeurs antonoff
donc ambassadeur de russie aux états
unis et sullivan ambassadeur des
etats-unis à moscou
on aura peut-être un accord sur la
reprise du fonctionnement normal du
travail des ambassades et des consulats
dans les deux pays puisque en 2017 un d
une représentation consulaire aux états
unis à san francisco avait été fermé par
la suite la russie a placé les
etats-unis en tant que pays hostile ce
qui fait que ils ne peuvent plus employé
d'employés russes dans leur ambassade
donc les activités de l'ambassade et du
consulat américain en russie sont
extrêmement réduites donc à mon avis on
parle de choses concrètes et
toutes ses excuses et moins encore pour
l'anglicisme et tout s'est fait que news
qui ont été utilisés pour pour faire
pression sur la russie à mon avis ne
seront même pas abordée tout le monde
sait très bien que c'est totalement
bidon cas alors on le disait je pense
que pour la pour aujourd'hui en tout cas
et pour tout le temps il pour jordan joe
biden on ne peut plus on ne peut pas
ignorer le poids de la russie cette
grande puissance mondiale
un contact tête à tête était très
important tout cas pour le président des
états unis
d'ailleurs joe biden a expliqué
récemment qu'il souhaitait une relation
stable et prévisible avec la russie où
il est possible de travailler ensemble
est ce que le domaine de l'armement
c'est un voilà un des points sur lequel
les deux hommes pourraient avoir une
convergence de vue tout à fait
d'ailleurs comme je le disais si le
général gherasim of le chef d'état major
de l'armée russe est là c'est bien pour
parler de ça il ya plusieurs familles à
la prolongation des des accords
internationaux sur le contrôle des
armements
il y as pourquoi pas remettre en place
le système de survol des territoires
communs aux russes et aux et aux
américains donc tout ça tout ça qui est
tout c'est toutes ces organisations dont
voulait sortir donald trump et bien il
est possible que le job hayden y revenir
et il faut dire aussi une chose c'est
que pour dubaï de la situation sera
beaucoup plus facile paradoxalement que
pour donald trump parce qu'il est clair
qu'il y avait entre vladimir poutine
donald trump une entente
du point de vue on va dire relations
humaines mais une fois rentré à
washington donald trump et est pieds et
poings liés par le congrès américain
puisque le congrès américain
systématiquement proposer des sanctions
les voter et comme plus des deux tiers
des votants était favorable à ces
sanctions donald trump et être tenus de
les appliquer ou
il était beaucoup plus difficile pour
lui de continuer dans sa dans sa voie de
rapprochement avec moscou
or joe biden lui n'a pas cette
difficulté puisque on va bien on ne va
bien sûr pas l'accuser d'être d'être pro
russe même si d'ailleurs vous avez des
sénateurs républicains un cocktail cruz
et même si donald trump d'ailleurs a dit
que le dr poutine allait à les manipuler
joe biden qui n'était qui n'étaient pas
de taille globalement si joe madden
prend des décisions en matière de
politique internationale
ce sera beaucoup plus facile pour lui de
les faire de les faire adopter par par
le congrès américain
donc comme les états unis encore une
fois sont demandeurs de cette rencontre
eh bien je pense qu'il y à il ya moyen
d'avancer sur sur certains sujets il
faut aussi noter que les russes en
fabriquant désormais de série toute une
gamme d'armes hypersonique que les
américains n'ont pas et n'auront pas
avant cinq ou dix ans les ce sont les
russes en fait qui dans ce domaine la
mène le jeu est d'ailleurs déjà à
l'époque donald trump dans l'est dans le
cadre des négociations sur les armements
voulait faire rentrer les armes
hypersonique dans ce domaine donc il il
ya de quoi faire et je pense que je
pense que on peut avancer sur certains
sujets il faut pas il faut pas partir
totalement tout le monde a dit qu'en
fait on n'avancerait pas que c'était le
premier contact
mais le parce que bien personne ne veut
être ne veut être déçu et surtout il
faut bien se rendre compte que dubaï
donne vis-à-vis de ses élites démocrate
vis-à-vis de son électorat doit avoir
dans l'est dans les déclarations
publiques une position extrêmement
hostile à la russie et à vladimir
poutine c'est pour ça qu'il a parlé
ligne rouge etc etc
mais les russes ne sont pas stupides
j'admire stupide va lire poutine n'est
pas stupide ainsi que ça gagne lavrov
et ils savent très bien que les chefs
d'état occidentaux que ce soit jo by day
nous-mêmes emmanuel macron disent une
chose pour leurs opinions publiques et
en font une autre au moment des
discussions qui de toutes manières
resteront secrètes pour ce qu'elles
auront de vraiment important
alors j'aimerais que l'on revient d'un
type et sur le rapport de force entre
ces deux grandes puissances et le timing
précisément de cette rencontre entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine on sait que
joe biden vient d'achever une tournée
européenne la première tournée depuis
son investiture à la maison blanche il a
rencontré les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement du g 7 ses alliés de l'otan
est ce que justement cela lui permet
d'arriver en position de force
à genève je dirais oui non parce que oui
il a rencontré ses alliés de l'otan il a
rencontré angela merkel mais angela
merkel a obtenu des états unis qu'elle
que les avis ne sanctionne pas nord
stream 2 ni d'ailleurs le directeur
général de l'ins crime de qui est un
citoyen allemand
donc en fait à mon avis une des
démarches aussi de joe biden va être de
sauver la face puisque la politique
américaine qui a été suivie tant par
donald trump que par joe biden par les
républicains les démocrates a échoué
pour empêcher la construction de nord
stream 2 donc il va falloir que joe
biden trouve le moyen de sauver la face
vis-à-vis de cela donc à mon avis on ne
râle une déclaration de la demi-heure
poutine qui va dire que oui nous sommes
prêts à maintenir un certain volume de
transfert de transit de gaz par
l'ukraine
de toute manière la russie à l'intention
de faire et c'est dans son intérêt de le
faire il faut pas se priver d'avoir un
système de transit comme celui de
l'ukraine
donc il y aura toujours un minimum de
gaz qui passera mais c'est pour ça qu'il
faut pas non plus oui effectivement il a
rencontré ses alliés mais il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui l'allemagne qui est le
grand pays d'europe occidentale qui et
je dirai l'interlocuteur quasi unique en
europe de de la russie et bien a obtenu
ce qu'elle voulait et a fait passer ses
intérêts économiques et énergétiques
avant avant l'alliance atlantique avant
la cette fameuse solidarité l'atlantique
qui qu'il n'est n'est pas en si bonne
position que ça en tout cas dans le
domaine énergétique
merci beaucoup en tout cas xavier moreau
d'avoir été en direct avec nous depuis
moscou je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur du centre d'analysé
politico-stratégique on va